[Musique]
mélanie peau qui est à présent avec moi
sur ce plateau bonsoir de la rédaction
de tv soixante dix huit pour découvrir
quelques rendez-vous loisirs de ce
week-end le premier mélanie va être très
musical c'est aussi l'occasion peut-être
de découvrir les talents de demain
puisque à magny les hameaux la maison de
l'environnement accueille la 5e finale
du tremplin des voix c'est le concours
de chant de la poire en scène c'est le
dernier palier à passer pour les 20
candidats c'est un concours qui prend de
l'ampleur
250 personnes se sont portées candidates
et 140 ont été auditionnés alors face à
un jury de professionnels mais le public
aussi vote
et oui le public a son mot à dire celui
de la scène mais aussi ceux qui vont les
regards des deux chez eux car le
concours va être diffusé en direct sur
youtube et nouveauté cette année c'est
aussi sur notre antenne le concours
débute ce samedi 1er février à 20h pour
un rendez vous plus intime il faut
plutôt se rendre à versailles
ah oui alors là on va partir plus
exactement au musée lambinet quatre
étudiantes de l'ue vs qui ont réalisé un
partenariat avec le site culture est
pour un événement alors on part au
xviiie siècle au coeur d'un hôtel
particulier le musée lambinet les
étudiantes vont vous qu'on vous ont
concocté un programme avec des visites
un récital avec des instruments d'époque
un atelier en partenariat avec
l'osmothèque ou aussi des jeux d'époque
et on écoute les précisions de l'une des
étudiantes
on essaye de faire venir un public varié
après en fait les étudiants c'est pas
forcément le public qui sera le plus fin
qui est le plus habitué à fréquenter le
musée lambinet donc le but aussi c'est
de faire venir des étudiants et présenté
voilà une un nouveau format qui
pourraient plus peut-être les intéressés
l'événement est gratuit
après il faut payer là le tarif d'entrée
au musée
donc c'est 6 euros et puis en tarif
réduit ses 4 euros donc c'est le 1er
février de 14h à 18h30
14h à 18h pardon à versailles donc au
musée lambinet alors si vous ne savez
pas quoi choisir pour une fois les
horaires vous permettent même de
profiter des deux rendez vous à votre
choix grégory merci mélanie comme
d'habitude on peut retrouver d'autres
idées de sorties dans le magazine 7,8
loisirs vous en êtes aux commandes et
c'est à retrouver sur tv 78 après ce
journal